إنها قصة مدينتين وسط جائحة واحد. من السكان العائدين إلى الوطن من الحالات الخارجية التي ارتفعت بشكل كبير خاصة في سنغافورة في 13 أبريل ، كان لدى سنغافورة أكثر من 2900 حالة بينما كان لدى هونج كونج 1009 حالة ، فكيف يمكن لهونج كونج مع عدد أكبر من السكان الذين يجلسون بجوار البر الرئيسي للصين أن تحافظ على الأرقام منخفضة على الأقل في الوقت الحالي هل سيقول المراقبون أنه يمكن أن يكون ذلك بسبب الناس هنا وظلت ذاكرتهم الجماعية لصلصة وبائية أخرى حية جدًا في ذكريات هونغ كونغ ، وعندما اندلع الالتزام التاسع عشر ، نحتاج إلى أقنعة نحتاج إلى أن نكون بعيدًا عن أحدهم آخر نحن بحاجة إلى التوقف عن أن نكون صحيين للغاية بشأن الأشياء التي نحتاجها للاستماع إلى الأشخاص الطبيين الذين نحتاجهم لإغلاق الحدود
البروتوكول الأساسي الذي أعتقد أنه موجود في
أي حكومة في حالات الأوبئة والأزمات ، كان
سكان هونغ كونغ يعرفون بالضبط
ما يجب عليهم فعله وقد فعلوا ذلك منذ ما يقرب من عقدين من
الزمن ، تسبب تفشي السارس في مقتل 774
شخصًا أقل بقليل من 40 في المائة من
الوفيات في هونغ كونغ.  في
بداية الوباء الأخير ، سارع سكان هونغ كونغ
إلى ارتداء الأقنعة أثناء تواجدهم في سنغافورة ،
لا تحتاج إلى ارتداء قناع إذا كنت
لا ترى إعلانًا للخدمة العامة الحكومية
يقول إن الأشخاص الأصحاء لا
يحتاجون إلى ارتداء أقنعة بعد شهور ، إنه
الآن  إلزاميًا لارتداء قناع خارج
أحد الاختلافات الرئيسية الأخرى.
المهاجع الضيقة التي غيرت مسار المدينة-الدولة
، قررنا أنه بدلاً من
التشديد التدريجي خلال
الأسابيع القليلة المقبلة  يجب أن تتخذ خطوة حاسمة
الآن لمنع
العدوى المتصاعدة ، فقد
أغلقت سنغافورة المدارس ومعظم أماكن العمل ،
كما تم حظر جميع التجمعات الاجتماعية
كجزء من قاطع الدائرة لمحاربة
الفيروس منذ البداية ، حيث قاموا
بفحص الحجر الصحي في تتبع الاتصال
وبعد أشهر من ذلك  Lion City
قيد الإغلاق الافتراضي وهذا هو الثمن
الذي يتعين علينا دفعه لمكافحة الأوبئة
مثل kovat 19 ، سيكون التباعد الاجتماعي
جزءًا لا يتجزأ من جميع
تدابير قواطع دوائر إغلاق قاعات الآبار ، لكن
الشيء المهم هو أنه يتعين على
الحكومة والشعب القيام بذلك
كن يقظًا إلى الأبد لأنه قد يغطي 19
عامًا هذا العام والعام المقبل ، ولكن
سيكون هناك أوبئة في المستقبل مع
تفشي المرض ، ولا توجد طرق مختصرة
فقط تم تعلمها من قصة مدينتين لا تزال
تتكشف كريستي لو
ستاوت سي إن إن هونغ كونغ